we are days away from the 2016 election
and the country hasn't been this divided
since way back a few weeks ago we were
all fighting about that picture of the
dog wearing pants or different ways I
don't know I don't know what the right
answer is they both seem plausible but
if there's one thing that can bring us
together its Starbucks ah Starbucks
there are new cup features a mosaic of
over 100 diverse people who would never
actually hang out in real life but it's
a nice thought meant to be a symbol of
unity and it worked because everyone
loves it oh wait they don't cuz in the
internet now that beloved diversity is
blown up in our faces the lives at
Starbucks have begun shilling for unity
lol cama cama cama how typical what does
that even mean how do you shell for
unity it's not a corporation it's a
concept how does this possibly anger you
take your meds fill up take them do you
not have a single real problem I don't
drink coke because the can is communist
red go and get me started on Twizzlers
that candy aisle is rigged it's rigged
people are using the cup as an excuse to
be angry much like I'm using it to be
sarcastic so comedians manufacture some
outrage about the delightful new
Starbucks copy Tiffani the cup doesn't
really represent actual Starbucks
customers where are the people that are
masturbating in the bathroom
well fapping a frappe that should be
their tagline Brian my coffee being
Aryan Nation travel mug holds way more
call to get out right you just use the
regular Starbucks cup but put Dunkin
Donuts coffee in there yeah way to do it
like Jim Jefferies